mais ce que bonjour merci d'être avec
nous à christian ciel vais commencer par
vous des manifestations qui durent un
oncle si on le voit depuis des mois même
si l'affluence diminue quelle lecture en
faites vous
j'écoutais qu'il ya un mal être on
s'aperçoit quand même que c'est une
manifestation qui partent quand même ya
plusieurs ya plusieurs manifestations
c'est pas une seule c'est pas une mais
deux manifestations unitaires que ya un
mal être que on vivait une situation qui
met beaucoup de gens mal à l'aise on
peut parfaitement le comprendre que des
gens s'en empare idéologiquement pour
essayer d'entretenir du venin ça existe
aussi mais on peut parfaitement
comprendre que les gens soient pas
heureux mais qui peut être heureux dans
des situations comme on la vit
aujourd'hui jara criblage des
manifestations en plein débat au
parlement sur la loi de vigilance
sanitaire est ce que dans ce contexte
ces manifestations peuvent avoir un
impact
je ne crois pas quand elles sont
dirigées par l'extrême moi d'ailleurs on
voit qu elles se réduisent à quelques
centaines de personnes par contre il ya
des milliers sûrement des dizaines de
milliers avec les gilet jaune et des
organisations syndicales qui exprime le
mal être dont on vient de parler
monsieur le mal être plus profond et sur
la question des salaires et sur la
question des licenciements qui sont
toujours eux pratiquée de façon abusive
il est sur la question des droits des
salariés qui sont toujours diminué
depuis les lois elles comrie pénicaud
landais macron il est question de
respect de la médecine du travail est
toujours extrêmement faible et qui n'est
pas prise en compte dans les nouveaux
textes actuels il est question du secret
médical vis-à-vis de l'employeur qui est
violet foulé aux pieds il est question
de l'ensemble des droits des salariés
qui sont dans ce texte piétiner dont on
ne parle pas parce qu'on ne parle que du
pass sanitaire moi je me suis déjà
exprimé mille fois je suis à 100% pour
la vaccination est à 100% contre le pass
sanitaires pour vacciner faut le
consentement des gens qu'on va le faire
par la force par la violence ni par la
bonnasse mai
c'est pas en disant on discute le 15
novembre le 22 février le 20 juillet
c'est pas ça qui compte oak le vaccin et
aux gens on sait qu'il ya encore 2
millions de personnes très âgées qui ne
sont pas vaccinés parce qu'il ya des
déserts madic médicaux parce qu'elle est
fracture sociale parce que des absents
informations parce que tout c'est pas la
répression qui réglera ce problème
le soulèvement les mobilisations les
doutes les craintes les méfiances des
gens viennent de ddd mille manoeuvre du
gouvernement matt ronde ses discours
successifs et en vérité la question peut
être tranchée que politiquement pour
établir la confiance faut se débarrasser
du gouvernement actuel qui a tellement
fait mal depuis deux ans depuis le début
on n'a pas eu ce match pas de gel pas de
lit pas de gagnant pas de curare pas de
médicaments pas de blouse pas de
seringue on n'a rien eu de tout a été
fait et donc c'est de là que se provoque
la situation actuelle on est un peu
entre deux situations quoi les gens
essaient de rattraper le temps perdu
elle tend retrouver ça sera quand tu
auras un million de personnes dans la
rue je souhaite de tout mon coeur contre
ce gouvernement mais l'ensemble de sa
politique en mettant le social d'abord à
l'ordre du jour et non pas en faisant
des diversions comme le fait le le
dirigeant politique nous avait montré
tout à l'heure
alors on va recontextualiser 1 c'est
vrai qu'il ya des manifestations contre
le pass sanitaires qui sont organisés
depuis des mois par des leaders
politiques mais aussi par des
particuliers il y a également ses
manifestations des jd jaune et qui ont
repris intensivement depuis quelques
samedis appelle même à la reprise des
ronds points pour dénoncer la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des français christian
sarthe on peut pas dire que c'est pas
une réalité
non c'est tout à fait une réalité on
voit même des familles qui n'en étaient
pas là et il a qui
sont en train de basculer a
effectivement devoir calculer beaucoup
plus encore qu'il ne devait calculer il
ya est encore quelques temps donc on
sent bien que l'augmentation de
l'électricité du gaz
le gasoil etc c'est vrai qu'il ya toute
une partie de la france qui a besoin de
prendre sa voiture pour aller bosser et
il ya quelques bobos parisiens qui n'ont
pas encore compris ça et qui disait ça
me rappelle un peu vous savez quand la
reine de france disait ils n'ont pas de
pain qu'ils mangent que de la brioche et
bien ils ont qu'à manger que de la
brioche bien on est à peu près comme ça
rapport à la situation d'une grande
partie des campagnes de la province où
nos habitants besoin de prendre leur
voiture pour aller bosser et que c'est
vrai que au niveau du 7e arrondissement
de paris l'ont pas encore compris
cette réalité du terrain et c'est
dommage parce que du coup elle se
traduit évidemment par cette réaction
plus de violences en tout cas plus
enragés de gens qui disent si vous vous
allez finir par comprendre parce que
nous on s'installe sur le point et on va
vous faire comprendre donc évidemment
qu'on sent cette bascule là est
évidemment qu'il ya la fracture elle est
vraiment dans la mentalité de gens qui
ne vivent pas du tout les mêmes
choses à faire c'est là son barreau 0
bondir sur les propos de monsieur on a
une fracture un clivage qui serait plus
au niveau des territoires aujourd'hui
plus que social
or je crois qu'elle est d'abord sociale
les territoires ses subordonnés il a
raison ce monsieur de parler du 7e
arrondissement de paris là où nous tout
se décide et ou ne comprennent pas qu'il
faut augmenter le smic massivement
évidemment le smic devrait passer à 14
cents ce ne serait qu'à un rattrapage en
est évidemment tout le monde a besoin
d'une augmentation uniforme pour tous
tout de suite de 300 euros c'est
simplement une mise à jour évidemment
qu'on peut pas vivre avec un salaire
médian à 1700 euros vous vous rendez
compte 50 % des gens veuillent moins
1700 ils peuvent pas s'en sortir
évidemment qu'on ne peut pas s'en sortir
avec les augmentations de l'essence des
tarifs des gaz et l'électricité
d'ailleurs au passage tout ce qui est
privé tout ce qui est privatisée ça nous
prive de ressources ils nous volent les
actionnaires ce total comme ceux d'edf
maintenant
ou comme ce qu'on veut mettre à l'aise
cf tout quand on est tout est privé on
est privé tout faut défendre les
services publics c'est vous avez bien
raison monsieur de dire que c'est la
balle en septième arrondissement ils
comprennent pas les services publics ils
comprennent pas la nécessité de la
gratuité des transports dans les grandes
villes et une comprennent pas qu'on a
besoin de voitures dans les petites
villes et dans les zones rurales et donc
il faut baisser la tva sur l'essence au
moins je suis pas langage
révolutionnaire vous savez la technique
et pédant temps qu'était une taxe aux
tentes et qui permettaient de compenser
les hausses c'était au moins mieux que
ce qui existe aujourd'hui la tva c'est
très injuste des villes et jaune ont eu
raison de le dire les syndicats aussi la
tva c'est une taxe proportionnelle qui
s'applique surtout solide pour les
salariés pas sur les riches quand il
achète une grippe et la tva quand il
achète une maserati ou une jaguar mais
la tv un coup de cherche pour celui qui
mène les sens dans sa mobylette et en
proportion celui qui mène naissance dans
un mobile edge ils souffrent davantage
est ce qu ont besoin d'une voiture parce
que c'est la condition pour vivre et
pour travailler ne peuvent pas tolérer
que aujourd'hui macron et castex annuler
ce qu'ils avaient fait sous la pression
des filets jaunes il y a deux ans tout
ça est annulée tout ça est en train de
sauter donc tout le monde voit que ce
gouvernement on n'arrête pas de le dire
mais n'importe quelle personne
interrogée dans la rue tu ne comprends
même pas comment les les cotes de
popularité de macron à l'ifop nous dit
ce qu'il en est là où il en est je les
crois pas parce que vous interroger
quelqu'un tout le monde nous dit qu'il
n'a cessé de dire qu'il n'a cessé de
contourner le problème en faisant que
toutes ces mesures est pour les riches
et que ce soit les pauvres qui paye et
il se propose de refaire la même chose
regardez la loi chômage qui est en train
de s'appliquer plutôt pas la loi chômage
la loi anti chômeurs 1 c'est une tuerie
cette loi elle est en train de se mettre
en place le 1er décembre l'application
va faire les gens vont perdre 30% de
leurs indemnités sommer les gens qui
sont au chômage vont perdre pied on nous
dit que le chômage baisse de ce n'est
pas vrai les gens passent d'une
catégorie à l'autre
c'est à dire qu'une baisse dans une
catégorie lui dans le total il est
exactement le même qu'avant et puis vous
dire le pouvoir d'achat augmenter qui
pouvoir d'achat avec monthey le
gouvernement serait pas obligé de donner
sens à tous on comme une espèce de monde
ce sont les salaires bruts nf qu'il faut
augmenter massivement savoir si la merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions à
christian charge merci à vous je
rappelle gérard filoche votre porte
parole de la gauche démocratique et
sociale monsieur seul tweet merli
centriste de la vie de jean brice merci
à vous deux messieurs